auch wenn der Slogan eigentlich zu VW
gehört ist ein Porsche 911 das Auto es
ist das Auto welches Serienmäßig
Rennsporttechnik Straßen zugelassen für
die breite Masse zugänglich macht und
gleichzeitig im Alltag einsetzbar ist es
ist das Auto welches Lebenstraum für
fast jeden Auto Fan ist und vor allem
aber ist es das Auto welches wir in
dieser Serie retten wollen viel Spaß mit
ich habe den günstigsten 992 GT3
Deutschlands gekauft für nicht Autofans
ist es vermutlich schwer zu verstehen
aber ich fühle mich verbunden zu diesem
Auto selbst ohne jemals einen besessen
zu haben es ist einfach das Maximum an
Ingenieurskunst was im Automobilbereich
möglich ist und das sag nicht ich
sondern so ziemlich jeder Autokenner und
Rennsportler die letzten Jahre habe ich
jede freie Minute genutzt um mir Fotos
Videos und Berichte über all die schönen
verschiedenen 1er anzuschauen das schier
unendliche Netz aus Generationen und
Versionen welchen könnte ich mir leisten
was muss ich tun um mir einleisten zu
können und welcher ist eigentlich der
richtige für mich und gerade diese Frage
ist gar nicht so einfach zu zu
beantworten denn es gibt el in
verschiedensten Generationen Ausführung
und Motorisierung angefangen beim
Urmodell welches den Start der 1 Serie
markiert dann G-Modell 964 993 996 997
991 bis zum 992 der aktuellen Serie
abseits davon dass es in den
Modellgenerationen noch mal Facelift
Modelle gibt welche quasi eine
überarbeitete Version der einzelnen
Generation sind gibt es unheimlich viele
Ausführungen welche für
unterschiedlichste Einsatzbereiche
gedacht sind grob zusammengefasst gibt
es in den Modellgeneration folgende
Varianten Carrera Modelle Sportwagen mit
besonders guter Alltagstauglichkeit und
sogar vier Sitzen turbomodelle
Sportwagen mit gute Alltagstauglichkeit
vier Sitzen aber deutlich mehr Leistung
und wie der Name es schon sagt eben
Turbo aufgeladen GT Modelle Sportwagen
für die Rennstrecke deutlich aggressiver
abgestimmt deutlich leichter und
präziser mit zwei Sitzen und
Straßenzulassung und die Sondermodelle
mit Referenz zu alten
geschichtsträchtigen Baureihen in neuer
Auflage mit modernster Technik innerhalb
dieser Varianten gibt es dann wieder
einzelne sp ikationen und Karosserien
91er Coupé also voll geschlossen Cabrio
also komplett einfahrbares Dach und
tager mit großer Heckscheibe und
einfahrbarem Dach aber welche Generation
in welcher Ausführung mit welcher
Karosserie ist denn nun der richtige für
mich gefahren bin ich bisher aus der
modernsten Modellgeneration 992 einen
GTS und einen gt3s der GTS war super hat
eine Menge Spaß gemacht ist super gut im
Alltag zu gebrauchen aber von all den
Fahrzeugen die ein GT im Namen tragen
vermutlich der der am wenigsten für die
Strecke und am ehesten für die Straße g
auf der anderen Seite ist der GT3 RS
komplett nur für die Rennstrecke
[Musik]
gedacht hat aktive Aerodynamik also der
Flügel klappt sich hinten hoch und
runter und ist überhaupt nicht im Alltag
zu gebraucht dazu liegt der aktuell bei
ca 450 000 € graumarktpreis was ungefähr
300 000 € mehr sind als ich zur
Verfügung habe und ausgeben will was
wäre wenn es genau zwischen diesen
Fahrzeugen ein Auto geben würde das
super hart abgestimmt ist für die
Strecke dass man wirklich gut auf der
Strecke bewegen kann das gleichermaßen
aber auch noch gut im Alltag und auf der
Straße funktioniert warte mal genau
dieses Auto gibt es und das nennt sich
GT3 das Problem selbst wenn ich das Geld
hätte so einen Auto zu kaufen würde das
nicht bedeuten dass ich so ein Auto
kaufen kann und das ist ganz einfach das
Interesse an diesen Autos ist höher als
die verfüg it bedeutet die Leute werden
ausgewählt so ein Auto kaufen zu dürfen
und nachdem ich über die letzten Jahre
mit vielen verschiedenen Porsche Centren
in Kontakt getreten bin musste ich
irgendwann akzeptieren dass es
vermutlich in dieser Modellgeneration
mit mir und dem 992 GT3 nichts wird also
brauchte ich eine andere Option
gebraucht kaufen kam für mich nicht in
Frage weil die Autos gebraucht teurer
sind als neu aus dem Porsche Centrum
weil das Interesse ebeno hoch ist und
mit ein bisschen Inspiration von der
ganzen Hamburger autobubble also ICO
Phil Max Hagen und so weiter ist es ist
für mich irgendwann in Frage gekommen
tatsächlich einen verunfallten Wagen zu
kaufen dann kam noch die zehnteilige
Serie von Matt Armstrong in der er ein
992 GT3 aufgebaut hat und irgendwann
habe ich mich dazu entschlossen das soll
auch mein Weg sein ich habe angefangen
zu suchen und dann über die letzten sech
Monate unheimlich viel recherchiert
unheimlich viel telefoniert und so viel
probiert vom Schreibtisch herauszufinden
wie es nur möglich ist bis ich
tatsächlich ein Auto gefunden hab der
Wagen sieht gar nicht scheiße aus finde
ich 100 netto
Alter das wä so geil ich habe so gerade
eben direkt gedacht Alter der ist in
Dortmund ich fahre da jetzt gleich
sofort hin die akribische Suche nach
einem 992 GT3 hat mir unfassbare
Flashbacks zu Porsche tradeup gegeben da
ging es auch darum dass ich mich
irgendwie zu einem Porsche hocharbeiten
kann und irgendwie bin ich bei diesen
Keramik Gießformen gelandet auf dem Weg
bis zu dieser Idee habe ich unfassbar
viele verschiedene Shops gesehen mit
super unterschiedlichen Produkten Shirts
Poster oder handgemachte Kunst wie diese
keramikmodelle und wie einfach das sein
kann sich mit einem eigenen Shop selber
zu verwirklichen zeigt shopify der
Partner des heutigen Videos shopify
bietet euch die Möglichkeit mit wirklich
jeder erdenklichen kreativen Idee in
wenigen Minuten super einfach ohne
Vorerfahrung und Vorkenntnisse einen
eigenen Shop zu bauen denn bei shopify
gibt's alles was ihr braucht in der
All-in-One Lösung dabei ist es völlig
egal ob es ein digitales oder ein
physisches Produkt ist oder was auch
immer es gibt unheimlich viele Templates
und auf jeden Fall auch eins das zu
eurer Idee passt live Analytics und
Statistiken helfen euch dabei eure
Kunden besser zu verstehen und am Ende
auch effektiver zu verkaufen genauso
mache ich es mit tarmac und all den
anderen Shops die ihr aus meinen Videos
kennt und was ihr noch aus meinen Videos
kennt sind strenglimitierte
collecttibles die ich immer passend zu
einer Videoreihe produziere und genauso
auch in diesem Format genau in dieser
Sekunde ist ein shopify Store online
gegangen den ich zum einen in wenigen
Minuten selber aufgesetzt hab und zum
anderen euch die Möglichkeit gibt erneut
ein kostenloses collectible zu sichern
ich will nicht zu viel verraten aber es
ist mit Abstand das krasseste was wir
jemals an euch verschenkt haben denn es
ist deutlich strenger limitiert und
jedes Teil ist ein handgemachtes Unikat
von uns wie immer seid aufmerksam in
diesem Video und findet das Passwort und
vor allem seid schnell ich habe shopify
über die letzten Jahre so viel benutzt
dass eine wirkliche Ehre ist sie bei
diesem Videos an meiner Seite zu haben
ich rate jedem von euch den Link in der
Videobeschreibung abzuchecken es mit
einem eigenen Shop mal auszuprobieren
ihr habt nichts zu verlieren es ist
super easy und ein mega mega power tool
also vielen Dank an shopify fürs möglich
machen dieser Videoreihe und euch viel
Spaß weiter mit dem Video ja in zwei
Tagen geht es Richtung Dortmund und den
vielversprechendsten 992 GT3 Unfaller
anschauen es ist unglaublich ich Fieber
seit vier oder 5 Jahren auf den Tag hin
an dem ich mir tatsächlich einen ne ELER
anschauen gehe mit echter Kaufabsicht
kein normaler keiner der perfekt ist
sondern einer der ein Unfall hatte der
überall kaputt ist den ich hoffentlich
wieder aufbauen kann uns kann im Prinzip
alles erwarten wir haben mega viel
rumtelefoniert so viel gecheckt wie es
geht aber am Ende entscheidet jetzt das
was heute passiert darüber ob dieses
Projekt existiert ob wir dieses Auto
nehmen könnenst preislich einig werden
ja ich kann es kaum abwarten robin ist
KFZ Techniker bei Porsche und
unterstützt mich das ganze anzuschauen
dazu haben wir einen Sportwagen
fahrzeuggutachter der mit mir schaut
weil wie gesagt die Karre ist so teuer
dass ich quasi nur einen Versuch habe
Restrisiko bleibt wir haben 7 Minuten
Fahrt
schauen uns die Karre an und dann
entscheidet das über die nächsten zwei
Monate Content über die nächsten Z
Monate Hauptaufgabe in meinem Leben und
wahrscheinlich auch über die nächsten
zwei Monate glücklichkeitslevel bei mir
servus
hi Heckscheibe
türchweller kompletter Flügel hinten
Heckstoßstange Aquaplaning Unfall also
wirklich einmal rundhum Blinker hier
vorne Lampen hinten komplett aber
grundsätzlich eine gute Basis für das
Projekt klar der Wagen ist kaputt aber
das Auto geht nicht
an also hier es den Wagen aus der Lücke
zu schieben um weiterzuschauen
bis der Wagen doch angingt mir ist ein
riesen Stein vom Herzen gefallen weil
wenn der Motor nicht laufen würde es
unheimlich viel mehr Arbeit bedeuten
würde bzw es sehr gut sein könnte dass
sich ein Wiederaufbau von dem Auto
überhaupt nicht lohnt das Problem wir
dürfen den Wagen nur so kurz es geht
laufen lassen dadurch dass der Kühler
beim Unfall kaputt gegangen ist kann der
Motor eben nicht gekühlt werden und es
könnte sehr gut sein dass er in
kürzester Zeit überhitzt was wiederum zu
irreparablen Schäden wie Kolbenfresser
und so weiter führen könnte was richtig
richtig scheiße wä also schnellst
möglich Fehler auslesen und hoffen dass
alles gut geht sind mehr als 100 Fehler
abgelegt und das geht jetzt erstmal
abzuprüfen welche Wichtigkeit hat das
welche aktiven Störungen oder sind schon
definitiv Bauteile als defekt halt
deklariert nach dem Auslesen der Fehler
galt es sich in kürzester Zeit ein
möglichst gutes Bild vom Auto zu machen
weil wir die Katze nicht im Sack kaufen
wollen und hier geht ein riesen shoutout
an mg exclusive raus bei denen wir das
Auto angeschaut haben die uns alles
haben machen lassen wir durften alles
abschrauben was wir denn auch selber
wieder dran bekommen und das haben wir
getan Kühler irendwo hier über den
Bordstein da sieht man h richtig das
Seitenkasten ja
aufgerissen hängt alles nur noch in den
Seilen hinter der Verkleidung das Blech
hat jetzt keine offensichtlichen
Verformungen GU wie die Gegenseite
aussieht da muss man ein bisschen
vergleichen je nachdem wie das
liegt so stellen
hier anderen Seite sieht auch noch
gerade aus das ist schon mal gar nicht
so schlecht wie gesagt drunter haben wir
ein kleines Loch
da müsste man dann schauen da kommt dann
Feuchtigkeit auch rein oder was den wir
das ganze Wasser so dann vorne in den
Vorderwagen reinlaufen D muss dann halt
schauen wie man das instand setzt also
hier vorne die Ecke geh wohl genau auf
dem Bordstein drauf und hat dann unten
so ein reingeschlagen den sieht man auch
ganz gut von hier oh ja da sieht man das
Ausmaß wie weit zieht sich das nach
hinten durch wissen wir nicht ne so
ziemlich genau bis zu vorderachstträger
ist nur dieser wandinsatz und
vorderachträger nicht vträger nicht das
hier ist das nächste Problem für
Karosseriebauer das wird hier
aufgeschnitten um zu gucken ob hier
drunter Probleme
sind sch mal rein das
Loch der innenholm irgendwo verzogen ist
aber es ist tatsächlich nur der
außenholm da fehlt tatsächlich
nichts wirehen durig der Schaden am
Vorderwagen also vorne am Kofferraum der
war uns nicht bewusst der ist richtig
Arbeit schät so auf 12 13 14000 € mega
der Hassel das schießt halt alles
komplett weg so ist das jetzt wenn an
den Preis nichts zu machen ist
eigentlich nichts jetzt müssen wir uns
überlegen zu welchem Betrag das für uns
machbar ist das Angebot machen entweder
die Jungs nehmen das an oder nicht aber
auf jeden Fall würde dieses Auto
deutlich mehr folgen en als gedacht weil
deutlich mehr Schäden als gedacht also
auch was gutes für euch moin Dave hier
wir haben gerade mit einem
Karosseriebauer gesprochen Angebot
bekommen ich wä bereit den zu nehmen ich
mE bruderpren aber das nie ma okay
willst du
zurückrufen ma ich okay tip top danke
dir C pa noch runter dann ich die
sche oh mein Gott komm mir bisschen
entgegen das könnte der Moment sein
indem ich ein fucking
992 GT3
kaufe jo hi
moin ich habe mal gesprochen ne J also
er wollte mal bleiben okay
aber von mir aus
wür ja weißt du was dann lass dann lass
uns das
machen okay dann machen wir das dann
passt das alles dann ist das auch fein
für euch alles klar geil mega vielen
Dank EBO CIA
Ciao ach du scheiße ich habe gerade
einen verunfallten
992 GT3
gekauft ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen
soll ich habe noch keine ST ich habe
noch keinen Karosseriebauer ich habe
noch keine Teile ich weiß nicht ob da
nicht noch mehr dran kaputt ist alles
was wir jetzt so sehen konnten wissen
wir aber darüber hinaus wissen wir es
nicht krank in zwei Tagen hole ich
meinen 992 GT3
ab ach du
scheiße das ist der Beginn einer neuen
[Musik]
Serie